and let's jump into the first story i'd
like to show you this tweet from elon
musk it is a meme it's a meme of me
and boy did this one trigger a lot of
people man but it's not so much about
the meme i i do want to highlight it
shows me say here's an example of
twitter's left-wing bias twitter says we
need to take into consideration the
context me then saying
the context is affected by your bias and
then twitter saying we need an example
of that and the cycle continues and i
give you another example well tim do
people understand that this actually
comes from your appearance with her on
joe rogan because i i actually think
people may not understand the concept
well i think a lot of people don't
understand that this is just summarizing
i went on joe rogan man this comes up a
lot now because this keeps becoming
relevant
and we had this conversation dude that
was huge that was huge yeah let me let
me help you guys understand because this
tweet's got 34 000 retweets what does
this tweet mean
during the show
i was sitting down with joe rogan vijaya
gaday the top lawyer the one who
reportedly cried at a meeting and jack
dorsey the former ceo
i said
you have banned many people for saying
learn to code
that is an example of your bias vijaya
god i said yes but you need to take into
consideration the context
they were saying that to harass people i
responded with no they weren't
that your interpretation of that is
based on fake news and leftist biased
media and she said i would need to see
an example of that to which i responded
here's an example
you suspended the editor-in-chief of the
daily caller
for
indirectly saying learn to code in a
quote tweet he didn't tweet it at
anybody i'm pretty sure that's what
happened right he didn't tweet it
directed at anybody he was like no i
don't think it was even a quote tweet it
was just a standalone tweet and they
suspended him for it that's right and
there were many other people who did not
direct learn to code
so i say that to her and then well you
gotta take into consideration the so so
that was a mistake but the context
around it okay here's another person
who tweeted
a blanket thing like people are saying
learn to code and it's funny banned
so this this cycle goes on and on in
this tweet though i want to show you
some other things because what this
really is about
this is about some shady goings-on we
talked about this yesterday but i think
we've got we have a mystery my friends
take a look at twitter let's pull up the
tweet again on the right side what is
this skateboarding is trending now tim
pool is trending okay i can't do
anything about that elon musk tweeted me
out but skateboarding dodgers at
diamondbacks now that's interesting now
this it says the black phone is trending
that's promoted
the what's happening tab for me maybe
maybe many of you have noticed this
has been consistently and overtly
political and it's typically leftist
politics it's typically saying something
about you know it'll say joe biden did
not shake hands with thin air according
to fact checkers that's always what's
going on in my what's happening all of a
sudden
it's like you like skateboarding tim
well i actually do like skateboarding
but you've never recommended that to me
before
something strange is going on and when
you look at some of these tweets let me
see if uh i'll pull this one up right
here
daily mail reports burning the evidence
before the new boss starts don jr and
right wingers see giant leaps in their
twitter followers after musk bid was
accepted let me see if i can pull up
this tweet because i might have things
out of order this is a a tweet from me
referencing the red-headed libertarian a
good friend of the show josie her
twitter handle is at trh official
that account was abruptly suspended
january 20th 2021
after she
pointed out that in a january 9th 2019
she predicted joe biden would run for
president and kamala harris would be the
vp a year later with no warning for no
reason she got suspended
that's it she didn't break any rules
why did that happen well just i believe
it was today she received an email
abruptly they reinstated her account
why
it is obvious at this point that the
drop-off of progressive progressives
their follower accounts are collapsing
and conservatives are rising it is not
organic twitter is lying there there are
journalists in the press claiming it's
oh twitter says it's organic they're
assisting in the lie
i think i think what they're doing is
they're they're playing a game of saying
it's organic because it's not bots so
it's not bad activity yes it is real
people that are leaving a lot of
progressives are leaving a lot of
conservatives are coming back but the
activity is not organic the activity is
artificial because this is the ban
hammer which had swung down on people
like josie people like so many others
that are getting these now it's being
lifted and they're magically coming back
i don't think progressives are leaving
sean king wouldn't even leave you know
he deactivates his account whoa whoa
sean king did leave for like 12 hours
right but i mean he came back and then
he came back and then he pretended like
he didn't leave and then
they're trying to call you out jack is
it right and then he was trying to call
me out as if i'd made it up and it's
like bro we all saw you take your
account down i'm gonna say it
i'm looking for the simple solution here
right i'm trying to make the least
amount of assumptions so when i see
you take a look at the the social blade
analytics yeah monday was the day that
elon musk it was announced would
purchase twitter at 2 53 p.m i know
because i was recording live i do all my
recordings for my main show live and at
2 53
the tweet comes out yeah okay
so you mean to tell me
the day and eight in the morning when
the wall street journal announced elon
musk's elon musk was in
negotiations with twitter like final
negotiations final negotiations it was 8
am not a single conservative said i'm
going to come to twitter and gloat not a
single one came and said let's cheer
this on not a single leftist said i'm
going to leave this is getting dangerous
okay fine maybe because it hadn't
happened yet by 2 53 p.m not a single
conservative joined twitter to tweet we
got it baby not a single one not a
single progressive said i'm leaving i
can't believe this just happened no they
all just for some reason waited 24 hours
they all said you know elon musk got
twitter back i would like to gloat as a
conservative i'm going to wait until
tomorrow to gloat i think that's because
the news broke the next day overnight
and they weren't responding to him
buying twitter they were responding to
the news telling them to be afraid of it
wrong well social there would there
would be a tiny tiny bump
when i track analytics and i've done it
for like a dozen different accounts you
would think you would see a five percent
increase at least right because this was
trending like crazy every major news
outlet was boom breaking breaking
breaking cnn had it on immediately you'd
think there would be a tiny tiny anomaly
so i gained maybe 1300 followers per day
you'd think monday i'd see 1500 if that
was true ian no it was the exact same it
wasn't until the next day i saw twenty
thousand the next day forty thousand
something happened overnight
and now when i look at the what's
happening tab
yo
now skateboarding is trending for the
first time for me in eight years yeah
i've been skateboarding my whole life
now they're recommending that to me i
want to add something to this when the
progressives are progressives losing
followers i don't think progressives are
leaving for the exact same reason you
would think there would be a small
anomaly
the day the news was announced of
progressive saying i'm gonna leave maybe
ian is right that many people didn't
notice until the next day when the news
was really all over the place but you'd
think at least some people in the know
would have left a small percentage one
percent two percent there is zero
anomalous data it is static like normal
and then the next day boom
5 000 followers gone 10 000 followers
gone no i think these were bot accounts
i think twitter was
i would i would i would argue
it's possible at least twitter was
involved in this we've already seen the
story from judicial watch where uh
the democratic party i think was in
california was requesting censorship how
much do you want to bet that was a dc
draino dc draenor that was dc well
that's his lawsuit okay he was censored
after request and i believe you know i
think i think judicial watch revealed
this we had tom thank you i think they
did it and then i know harmy dillon is
working on that one as well where his
censoring actually came at the behest of
the california government and what
judicial watch got was the act where
they're getting the actual receipts the
documentation that shows that i'm
willing to bet
that twitter was operating fake accounts
for the sake of quote-unquote health of
the platform that is the platform was
overwhelmingly being dominated by
right-leaning voices that liberals were
overwhelmingly rejecting wokeness
a healthy platform a good balance
between left and right right well the
problem is former hippie skateboarding
liberal types and left-wing types like
tim poole all of a sudden are saying we
gotta vote for trump
the scales had shifted how much you want
to bet twitter said we've got to we have
the mission on our hands so we're going
to ban a good chunk of the right we're
going to artificially inflate the left
to fake the health of the conversation
well i think that almost gives them too
much credit for doing something
that's to the benefit of the whole
and i think there may be an element of
that thought process in there but i do
think there was a big element as in
california of political figures and
corporate figures able to call the shots
with twitter so that some of the balance
or what may look like balance is
actually
influence and i think that's what makes
the case for
twitter not just being a private company
that can make its own policies which is
what people say when there's a question
of do they have the right to censor
people say well it's a private company
it's not really i argued in the last
book that i wrote that
it is a quasi-official public government
organization because of its contracts
because it is beholden to the government
because it fears regulation if it
doesn't abide by certain rules and
requests and it has admitted to
taking directives from political figures
and members of congress
who were not elected by us to control
twitter but that's exactly what they've
been allowed to do let me address that
the path to hell is paved with good
intentions the people at twitter think
they're on a glorious mission to save
humanity
but if you have
the majority of the american people
saying wokeness is not good
and you end up with post liberals these
are people who voted for democrats i was
i was supporting bernie sanders in 2016
and i did not vote for trump now here i
am having voted for trump and the
republicans in 2020.
that is them saying uh oh something bad
is happening because our worldview is
being rejected in reality they are
insane psychopaths thought
how how do we save the balance of the
system i know as sic as psychopaths we
need to create the perception that
psychopaths are actually normal
they are
just because they have good intentions
doesn't mean they're not doing evil
right so so the path to hell is paved
with good intentions they think they're
good people they're not i can i can echo
that man as a social media administrator
for like six five or six years at mines
you what would happen is you'd get
people would be boosting stuff and
they'd be posting stuff and i'd go
through and i'd be like okay all
politics are not safe for work i want to
keep that conversation in its own area
and then i'd see something would come up
that i would agree with and i'd be like
wow i don't i agree with that and i want
that message to be propagated but my job
as an admin is not to make that decision
i have to put that in the bucket with
all the other politics for instance
tim's work he'd make a video and it
would be cogent and i'd be like well
it's politics so it goes with the
politics and it takes a strong mind to
continuously do that i don't think any
human is really capable of setting their
emotions aside like that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there
you